cái bé mà bán Cho tui cái máy móc tuyệt bố mày nè
là bán lén á nó bán lén lắm
một 2 BA
a
không phải là tui
biết SAO hông
người đầu tiên có
thì chắc chắn là các bên mà người trung gian
lấy cái cái cái dòng BG
về Việt Nam chứ em không phải là người đầu tiên
dù là mình mua được nhưng mình cũng không được xài
boxer 4 ha bây giờ tất cả mọi người không AI được
active cái a cái a boxer 4 hết mua thôi
đến ngày 22 thì dòng DJ mới chính thức gọi là ờ là mở bán
và cũng chính thức gọi là hoạt động tại tất cả các nước
Theo như thông tin cái người bán Cho em nó nói là như vậy
em rất là mê cái dòng của DJ
mọi người biết rồi đó em là fan cuồng tín đồ của DJ luôn
cái dòng giống như là flycam nè ha
action năm action 6 nè ha
các cái mic của DJ là cái mic này
hôm bữa em mua bên Hàn là 9.000.000 hay gì nè
9.000.000 hay 8.000.000 gì hôm bữa em có quay đó mọi người
trệt BA trời ơi em nói thiệt á em là fan cuồng luôn á
cuồng cực kỳ luôn
em nói thiệt nha có những dòng mua chả xài được
chả xài được ở đây là SAO có nghĩa là thực Ra là mình không
rành để mà mình xài thôi
đó mua mà hổng xài được nhưng mà vẫn mua tại vì quá mê
bây giờ em cũng gọi là phải ráng đợi
tại vì cái bé mà bán Cho em nó nếu như á mà anh hả
mà attract nó kiểu như là
mở lên mà hoạt động á mà kết nối với lại cái điện thoại
coi như là cả cuộc đời này
em không bao giờ bán được cái hàng của DJ
nó không bao giờ Cho em nhập luôn
tại nó Cho nhập thôi chứ nó không Cho được quyền bán
cũng như không Cho được quyền mà mở
nên là em sẽ che
nên những cái thông số này Kia nha mọi người ơi
nên là cái trên cái dưới là mọi người sẽ không thấy
bây giờ nè vô vô vô nè vô nè vô nè
đây âm thanh của đồng tiền
bao nhiêu clip
em cũng nói với mọi người là mỗi nước em đi
sẽ mua xài một cái máy mới
mà mỗi nước em sử dụng cái máy mới là trúng chữ em tan nát
tại vì SAO nói
Panda ơi quay gì mà 6 chưa vậy em
SAO em hả nhiều máy móc mà em quay 6
vậy đây là những cái dòng
action thôi nha
còn những cái máy cơ là em để trong Kim
mấy cái máy cô á thì biết SAO hông
cầm á thì phải là người chuyên cầm những
cái máy đó quay mới được còn thường em đi là bé mai nó quay
người ta quay giùm
chứ bộ người ta quay chuyên nghiệp đâu mà
người ta quay đẹp
có nghĩa là quay
nhiều khi cũng phải cầm nguyên một cái cây rim bồ nè
để nó hông có giựt
nó hông có rung
nên nó rất là nhiều cái bút
tiện em nghe là từ tháng 12 năm trước là sẽ có
đợi đến giờ không có mấy má bây giờ mới bắt đầu có nè
lí xí clip này Xin phép ồn nha
thường thường clip nào cũng ồn mà hôm nay a Xin phép thêm
trời ơi đây nè nó sẽ có một cái túi và một cái túi
cái bé này bán Cho em đó là bây giờ anh mở Ra
anh mở máy lên vẫn được mở lên coi camera vẫn bình thường
nhưng anh đừng
có mà gọi là kết nối nói với điện thoại giùm em
AI anh anh mà kết nối nói với điện thoại
coi như là em với lại DC là mất cái nối
trời ơi đây nè tủ túi mới cũng xinh luôn nha
mọi người ơi em nói thiệt nha
phải Chi mà bồ mình mà tặng Cho mình một cái này
ta nói là mê luôn
ta nói là nó đã bỏ
mình bỏ hông nổi luôn mà mình bỏ nó hông nổi luôn mà nó
trời như ổ bánh mì vậy đó cái
đầu tiên là cái lông
gắn vô vít ủa này nó có tặng vít hông ta
tiếp Theo nha vẫn là cái lông nha mọi người ơi
có tặng 2 cái mít luôn à hông tặng có con mít à
đây nó tặng mình một cái mít nha
mà mít lần này là hình như là dòng mít ơ
mít mới Ra nè
hình như là cái dòng mít mà em xài là mít BA hay SAO á
nè cái mít BA nè
đó là một luôn á
a cái đèn
lần này nó Cho đèn nữa nè mọi người nó Cho cái đèn nữa nè
ê SAO mà tinh tế thế vậy
đây đây đây đó cái đèn để gắn vô nè
hồi hộp quá đi hồi hộp quá đi ô
lần này là cái a cái cục nhỏ
đây là cái cục nhỏ để gắn cái chân đế
rồi à dây đeo nè rồi cái a dây cáp
nóng vội quá nóng vội quá
à đây cái chân gấm nè đây là gì nữa
a cái Len ồ
hồi đó em cái a bóc chìa BA của em mất cái Len thôi thôi
giờ cò cất lại đi mất công mất nữa
và cuối cùng là bóc đẹp hông
mặc dù nha em nói thiệt nha
đồ công nghệ là xài là quay là 6
nha em nói thiệt em chân thành là không có một cái a
gọi một đứa nhà sáng tạo nội dung nào mà
quay nhiều cái màu mà 600.000
em nói thẳng một câu em biết luôn
nhưng mà SAO hông kệ nó thích vậy đó
còn AI á mà thích góp ý á tự mua tự xài vậy nha
chứ trời vô trời quá trời
SAO mà mà mua mà hổng biết xài mà mua Chi trời
kệ người ta chứ trời
kêu tui có Xin tiền mấy người đâu kệ người ta chứ trời
ha ha ha thì bây giờ chuẩn bị là anh bóc em nè đó
đó trồi ôi SAO mà mê quá vậy trồi ôi thôi mà dán lại đi
em là bị cái kiểu là rất là ghét trầy nha
nên là giờ này mua miếng dán đi ủa
ê à có cái đồ gỗ luôn mọi người ơi biết SAO hông
mấy cái bóc kẹt nó rất dễ bị hư cái trục đó
nên là kiểu bây giờ là bóc kẹt cũng đã Cho một cái
cái đồ gắn ghi mà định hình trục một
2 BA
UI
đây nè khui khui khui khui khui đó
đó đó mở lên vậy thôi đó thôi thôi tắt nha
chừng nào được xài lại quay clip Cho mọi người coi nha
tới đây thôi nha mọi người ơi đợi ngày 2 2 nha
em là chuẩn bị em đi Thổ Nhĩ Kỳ
lần này em sẽ quay bằng bóc kẹp
nghe nói là nếu như quay bóc kẹp mình biết hậu trì á mình
quay bằng brown này
Kia lên màu rất đẹp nhưng mà hổng ừm
mấy bạn editor của em thì hông biết là đổ màu của rau
hông biết là mấy bạn có biết hông
hay là AI biết đổ màu rau á ờ
để Cho màu đẹp á thì vô làm chờ làm editor em luôn
em nói thiệt có gì mọi người liên hệ em
em mê gọi là mê đắm mê đuối cái dòng mà cái dòng của DJ
á tại em thấy là cái màu của nó nó bị xinh lắm mọi người ơi
còn AI mà thích kiểu mà
mà mà màu nét á thì là không thích mà hợp với màu DJ nha
tại màu DJ thì nó sẽ hơi bạt bạt bạt bạt bạt bạt
nó kệ em các kiểu vậy đó
mà mong lần này nó sẽ nét hơn bình thường
có nghĩa là nét hơn là SAO
có nghĩa là Ra clip á nó nét hơn xíu đó
còn màu của nó thì nó cứ bạt bạt vậy cũng được
ủa em nhớ là có AI nói là nó tặng Cho một cái ơ cái ốp
nguyên một cái cục ốp mà
mà mà gắn vô mà ta SAO em hông có ta bóc kẹp BA
nó sẽ có nguyên một cái đồ gắn vô vậy nè
SAO cái này nó hông có đồ gắn vô ta
hay cái thiếu gì vậy trời
à nó Cho cái túi nữa à
nó Cho có cái túi à
nếu bây giờ em để chấm điểm đi nếu mà là bóc kẹp BA
em Xin được chấm là 7 điểm
nó chỉ bị một vấn đề là quay tối không đẹp lắm thôi
với lại là nó sẽ cái màu
của nó sẽ hơi bệt một chút xíu
nó bị lệ thuộc vào ánh nắng phải nắng đẹp quay nó mới đẹp
nắng không đẹp là quay nó rất là oh my god
luôn BA 60 là em Xin được chấm là 6 điểm
tiện dụng nhưng mà để xuất Ra một cái file cực kỳ khó khăn
em có rất là nhiều clip trong đây
nhưng tới giờ em làm biếng em không xuất file
luôn á quá làm biếng phải còi canh gốc canh gốc
canh gốc canh gốc
cái instax này nếu như được chấm điểm
em Xin được chấm là BA điểm
cực kỳ vậy đó
mấy màu sắc thì thực sự là phải dùng
mọi người đổ tự đổ màu thì nó đẹp nha chứ
màu thuật trên đây mà để mà
em nó canh bao nhiêu lần mà em vẫn thấy nó không đẹp
còn với action 6 thì em Xin được chấm là năm điểm 75
ổn định được
nhưng mà là dành Cho những cái bạn mà thích quay mà kiểu mà
đi mà trích kinh này Kia đó đi mà Phương này Kia á quá hợp
quay xuống nước đẹp ô kê
còn lại mà để quay daily vlog á
thì nó lại không hợp
em đang chấm trong cái sự phù hợp với em
và em cũng nói lên sự phù hợp của tất cả mọi người
chứ em không dùng cái sự cá nhân của mình để áp đặt lên nó
nếu như mọi người thích sự action
sự là nhanh gọn này Kia siêu hợp
không thể nào có thể địch lại nó luôn
bất kể là không có cửa
tại vì SAO bất kể là mỗi lần mà phải quay
xoay qua xoay lại rất là bất tiện
mọi người coi mấy cái clip em đi a đi a
Ai Cập á em quay bằng này rất là tiện nha
quay bên đây người ta nói là quay qua em liền là
mọi thứ nó bắt trọn trong cái clip này luôn
nên là nó khá ô kê
nhưng mà màu của nó thì thật sự là BA chấm
thật sự bây giờ nếu mà bây giờ
action mà nâng cấp cái màu lên á bây giờ
kêu mà bây giờ em bán là
năm 10.000.000 em mua luôn vì
fashion chỉ cần 10 mấy triệu thôi
bây giờ mà 50.000.000
nhưng mà màu sắc nét đẹp chấp nhận luôn
tại vì nó vừa tiện dụng mọi thứ rất là tiện trong tầm Tay
nhưng mà chắc rất là khó
tại vì SAO máy móc chip
này Kia nọ đó nó phải là một máy bự thì mới được
còn cái flycam này nếu như được
chấm điểm tôi Xin được chấm là 6 điểm 75
màu sắc rất đẹp thật sự nét mà còn đẹp nữa
khuyên bị một cái là tui không biết xài mua
tới tận ngày hôm nay
không biết xài mua từ cái chuyến đi man deep á
và tui phải sử dụng cái máy của cái anh phòng kế bên ảnh
kêu là bây giờ ảnh quay giùm Cho chứ
tui không biết xài cái máy
tới tận ngày hôm nay vẫn chưa xài nữa luôn
không biết xài AI biết xài được rảnh rảnh chỉ em cái nha
bé mà bán Cho tui cái máy móc kẹp bố mày nè là bán lén nó
bán lén nó kêu là em thấy anh mua em hoài
nên là em mới bán Cho anh đó chứ
nhưng mà anh không được Cho
thấy cái số trên đây và không được Cho thấy cái số dưới đây
một phát nha ta nói là
bán một cái là em đi thỉnh kinh luôn đó
nói Chung là không bao giờ được bán
cái dòng này bên đây nữa
là người ta
đưa Cho em thôi chứ người ta chưa có Cho bán Ra ngoài đó
bởi tui Xin được biết cái tên của bé đó lại nha đó là về
tui cũng rất là nghiêm túc
tui chưa có kết nối với lại cái máy a
danh dự nha đến ngày 2 BA con này
kết nối nhiều khi là bây giờ sợ
quá giờ là
giờ giờ nhắn tin nó thì là nó Cho kết nối với em kết nối đó